-Que je vienne demain matin, à 7 heures au boulot..
-Oui voila j'espère que ça ne te dérange pas
-Non non non.. Ça me dérange pas vous savez, je suis du matin
Moi, me lever tôt, j'adore ça...
-Très bien ! Je compte sur toi ! À demain !
- Voilà, au revoir ! À demain !
Blaireau, va !
-Tu as mal raccroché le téléphone...
Oh ! Ah ! Des blaireaux chez moi ! Allez ouste ! Sales bêtes ! Allez vous-en ! Ouste ! Sales bêtes...de blaireaux !
Aaaah ! La vie en entreprise ! Hein... c'est génial ! Avoir des collègues relous, des patrons dictateurs à mi-temps ! Le...le pied, quoi !
Je suis pas fait pour la vie en entreprise, hein, je suis nul en patron ! Je sais pas comment m'y prendre ! Je sais pas si je dois tutoyer ou vouvoyer mon patron
Par exemple hein, si je le tutoie et qu'il faut pas, je suis fiché ! Si je le vouvoie et qu'il faut pas, je suis fiché aussi... Alors j'ai trouvé une astuce...
Le..."tu dis rien !"
- Bonjour Cyprien, ça va ? - Oui ça va, et, et, et, et, et, et j'imagine que ça va ? - Oui ! Ça va merci ! - Bonne journée !
Des années d'entrainement. D'ailleurs en parlant de patron, je sais pas si tout les boss sont comme ça mais si c'est le cas :
Où est-ce qu'ils ont trouvé leur humour ?
L'humour de patron, hein c'est peut être le truc qui fait le moins rire sur terre derrière la chasse des bébés phoques.
Qui ça fait rire, ça :
- Bah alors Cyprien, on est parti plus tôt hier soir ?
- Ah oui, en fait je devais aller chercher ma fille à l'...
- Beh, j'vais devoir vous virer comme ça vous serez encore plus tôt chez vous.
*musique triste*
- Ahahahah.. Elle est bonne hein ?
*rire*
Super drôle !
Après, il y a différents types de patrons, bon, moi par exemple je connaissais pas dans le film "Comment tuer son Boss" ils parlent des patrons "nymphomanes", avec Jennifer Aniston
Moi, je donne de l'argent pour avoir un boss comme ça, hein, elle a le double de mon âge, elle pourrait être ma mère, je.. je m'en fous, Jennifer, embauche-moi, je suis ton objet, fait moi faire ce que tu veux, des trucs interdits par la loi si tu veux, oui.
J'veux bien te rejoindre aux États-Unis, d'accord, c'est par où, c'est.. par là bas c'est ça ?
Ok !
Mais finalement j'crois que le pire, c'est, c'est être stagiaire, attendez : vous pensez qu'être stagiaire, c'est enrichissant professionnellement ?
*rire*
Ah vous êtes mignon.
Dans la pyramide de la reconnaissance, on a :
- les esclaves puis
- les insectes et enfin..
- les dictateurs et en dessous..
- les stagiaires
Nan, nan mais sérieux quoi, les stagiaires, on leur demande que des tâches ingrates !
Des tâches inhumaines !
Faut voir ce qu'on ma demandé !
Stagiaire là !
Cyprien.
Oui c'est ça.
Tu peux me scanner un truc ?
Le seigneur des anneaux.
La trilogie recto-verso.
Et tu fais ça vite.
Tu vois les cartons là-bas ?
C'est les archives des 10 dernières années,
tu peux enlever toutes les agrafes avec tes ongles ?
On va mettre des trombones à la place.
Houla, elles sont super sales mes lunettes ! Tu peux me les nettoyer ?
Avec ta langue.
Surtout les croûtes sur les branches, là.
Alors, tout le monde vous le dira,
le mieux c'est d'être son propre patron.
C'est bien une phrase toute faite ça :
Être son propre patron.
Ça ne veut rien dire ! Hein ?
On ne peut pas être son patron,
et son employé.
On ne peut pas être les deux en même temps.
Sauf, si t'es schizophrène.
Excuse moi,
tu peux m'apporter un café ? S'il te plait ?
Oui pas de problème !
Tenez !
Merci !
Hum...Il est vraiment très bon !
C'est parce que j'ai changé de marque !
T'as changé de marque ?
Ah très bonne initiative !
Oui c'est une petite marque de café dans mon épicerie,
au fait tu en es où du dossier sur les américains ?
Euh chérie ?
Je crois que le voisin est rentré de l’hôpital.
J’appelle le stagiaire ?
Oui appelle le stagiaire !
Stagiaire ?
Oui ?
Est-ce que tu peux venir pour la réunion ? C'est le boss qui t’appelle !
D'accord, pas de problème !
Merci d'être aussi nombreux sur ma page Facebook,
et retrouvez toutes mes autres videos sur cyprien.fr
C'est vrai que ça part mal les croûtes.
Contribution aux sous titres : Gabriel Decote